this is Jocko podcast number 186 with me
jakka willing among the newly minted
Special Forces soldiers were Douglas L
Letourneau a skinny 135 pound California
cowboy John Shore a blond-haired
slightly overweight baby-faced kid from
Georgia and Frank mcklusky a tough
combat hardened veteran of the hundred
and first Airborne Division
McCloskey arrived sporting seepage from
a wound in the back of his head this
trio of Green Berets had completed their
Special Forces in-country training
program in NHA trang the 5th Special
Forces Group Headquarters when a
sergeant NHA trang asked for Special
Forces soldiers to volunteer for a
secret project they raised their hands
in short order they were flown to fo b4
in the northern sector of South Vietnam
I Corps upon reporting in they were told
camp commander Colonel Jack Warren would
brief them in the morning on the CNC
mission in Southeast Asia finally after
more than a year of training for
Letourneau the game was on how much
better could this get it seems all his
life he'd been preparing for this moment
from riding Rodeo Bronx and breaking
nearly every bone in his body to
wrangling animals for television shows
like Daktari and cowboy in Africa
starring Chuck Connors Letourneau knew a
little bit about taking a calculated
risk and after he had gotten his hands
on Robin Moore's book of the Green
Berets he knew this was for him
guerrilla warfare check
counterinsurgency training check
unconventional warfare check Letourneau
couldn't wait to write his own story
that he could someday share with his dad
a world war ii b-17 pilot and former
POWs
however could have prepared him for the
sight that greeted him as he entered the
transient barracks
they're etched onto the concrete floor
and forever in his memory was the
charred outline of a man's body a grisly
reminder of the 23 August 1968 attack on
FO before that fateful evening North
Vietnamese sappers and Vietcong
operatives killed 18 Green Berets in a
carefully executed sneak attack the
deadly side of guerrilla warfare was
brought home to him right there he was
in a war zone the enemy didn't play by
any set rules it was an unsettling event
the next morning after breakfast the
trio walked over to a three and chose
their codenames Letourneau McCloskey and
Shore now became the Frenchman namu and
Bubba names that would stick with them
far beyond their tours of duty in
Vietnam because s3 was temporarily
located in the headquarters section of
FO b4 since the attack it was a quick
shuffle into the briefing room with
everyone else an intense short an
intense short black haired man wearing
pajamas slippers and a bathrobe walked
in smoking a cigarette before a word was
spoken Colonel Warren abruptly pulled a
white sheet off a large map with a
flourish and toss to decide and
announced welcome to C&C men turning to
the large map that had black tape boxed
target designators on it in laos the DMZ
and north vietnam he continued this is
what you volunteered for this is why
this is a top-secret project if anybody
asks the president can say we have no
men stationed in the AO that is why
you'll wear sterile fatigues and carry
no form of identification of any kind on
your missions that's why you agreed not
to talk to anyone about this operation
for at least 20 years our Intel reports
land in the White House any questions
not waiting for a response Warren
continued to explain the difference
between spike teams and Hatchett force
elements where the different fo B's were
located how fo b3 at Khe Sanh was closed
after the siege earlier in the year
and how major Clyde sincere jr. had
opened a site at my lock now designated
fo b3 following an update on
intelligence reports in the respective
areas of operations Colonel Warren asked
if anyone had any questions Letourneau
raised his hand where do you need help
sir we need men at fo b1 we lost a10 on
October 5th and some of the 1st Special
Forces TDY troops from Okinawa are
returning back to the island the turned
to shore and McCloskey and asked how
about it fo b1 sure nodded in the
affirmative
McClosky said no I think I'll stay here
Letourneau turned back to Warren and
said we'll go nodding toward shore
surprised at McCluskey's response
without missing a beat Warren told the
remainder of the SF troops in the room
that he'd be right back
he turned a litter no inshore and said
follow me as he headed out of the
briefing room and into the s3 Operations
Center he told the center staff to get a
king bee to fo before in an hour to
transport Letourneau and shore to fo b1
ASAP next he headed to s1 and told the
clerk that the newbies were to be
processed and cleared to go to phu by an
hour later PFC Letourneau and speck
foreshore were in a king bee heading
north to fo b1 and that right there is
an excerpt from the book across the
fence which was written by John Stryker
Myer nicknamed tilt was a Special Forces
soldier and SOG recon leader in Vietnam
and we went deep with tilta on podcast
180 181 and 182 and if you haven't
listened to those podcasts and stopped
this one right now and go back and
listen to those first but if you have
already listened to those podcasts then
you heard a little bit about Doug
Letourneau codename the Frenchman and
you know that he was also a Special
Forces soldier a green beret and was
also a SOG team member in Vietnam and it
is an absolute honor to have
not only tilt back again on this podcast
but he brought with him the Frenchman
himself
Doug litter know the one and the only
gentleman thank you for coming on good
to see you again good evening sir good
evening thank you for having us they had
great to meet you great to have you both
here and yeah let's talk a little bit
about how you ended up that I mean we
you you go you glaze over in the book
we're ridin rodeo Broncos we're working
in Hollywood taming and animals what was
your upbringing that got you to do that
you there believe it or not I was born
in East LA in the barrio well that makes
sense
yeah not yeah but no so living in the
city
I got fortunate enough when I got into
high school then I got into a program
called the Future Farmers of America and
it gave me a whole different way of
looking at life and I ended up becoming
a president of the chapter but I had
several Spanish speaking in Spanish
people in our chapter one of the largest
in all of Southern California as it
turned out well with these people I
could became such good friends and their
way of life and we're still working the
fields of the San Fernando Valley which
was still open I tended to lean towards
the country way of life even though I
was born and raised in the city and I
knew nothing about anything at all but
city life but I tried to break away from
that through the organization and the
western end of the San Fernando Valley
well one thing led to another and I
learned about you could go rodeo and
there was a place that I could go ride
in practice we could do bull riding and
bronc riding and bareback riding and all
the three were severed and no rally
this was actually out in thousands oaks
okay at the Paramount Studios okay yeah
they had a ranch right there
and D Cooper's is what it was called in
those days and we could go out on a
Wednesday night and Saturday and Sunday
and ride and have jackpots and I got
into it and then one thing led to
another I got into college and I got on
the college intercollegiate team and we
traveled in Brodie Oden and as I went
through college I became adept to it and
got into Ropin with rope and horses and
own my own rope horse and it's just the
way a life changed from being a city
slicker to to a cowboy where did you go
to college I started out at Pierce
junior college at the in Woodland Hills
I'm cocky the Safran out of Valley and
then ended up with Cal Poly San Luis
Obispo a Mustang er yeah so through
courses there and but basically we just
just kept on going and then with the TV
series that were popular with a lot of
animals there was an opening to be a
wild animal trainer at Africa USA in San
Canyon New Hall so I jumped up there how
old are you at this point I'm night I'm
20 yeah okay well the animal trainer
sounds like you know well another day in
college there you go
so I jumped up there and before I knew
it I was handling Clarence to cross out
of line Judy the chimp and then they had
a rope horse there that what they used
it and they wanted me to call Dakota
Duke and they wanted me to go out and
capture all these animals by roping them
and they knew I could row there's actual
picture of me on the front of the Piggin
string that was produced out of
Lancaster Antelope Valley me on the
front cover roping a tiger off of this
horse off this horse and that's what I
did and I roped elephants and I wrote
you know he'll demand I healed giraffes
and and
I headed up White Rhino form it was
coming at us and I turned him back and
you know where they would do all these
what they call a veil a veil would be
open land it's a it's a African term and
we just would turn these animals loose
but somebody had to go get them
so I I actually got to work on the on
the TV series that was very popular
called Daktari and people would see the
trucks they were zebra trucks I went on
YouTube and checked out some Daktari old
footage like a classic show really and
but it was shot in like Africa but
actually was all done right there knew
all saugus you know at the compound and
so from there we ran into a series
called cowboy in Africa we brought Chuck
Connors in it and he was the star and
hugh o'brian had actually done the
original movie there's of cowboy in
africa and they shot it in africa but
here they're going to shoot it here in
the united states and so i got to work
with ostriches and all kinds of
different animals that they had to have
around the compound of the house that he
was working out of in the series but one
thing left to another but as it turned
out one night somebody handed me an old
ragged book it's called the Green Beret
by Robin Moore and I looked at it and I
read it and I couldn't put it down and I
said this has got to be something that
this Vietnam War has been going on for
quite a while I grew up almost listening
to it every day there's got to be
something going on that I need to
contribute and I think this is what I
want to do I went down the next day very
next day and signed up what - what year
was that how old were you I was 20 and
this was like September just before it
was like well I say because I went in
September first so it was the day before
so
you know August 30th oh wait you're
though 1968 1966 or 77 67 yes and I
actually entered the service in late
September 1st 1967 yeah by that time he
had obtained a college degree by
attending classes at night so instead of
going through the 4-year program the
college with three years well I
graduated when I was 17 okay from high
school from high school guy was early in
with the classes at night yeah as spare
time and and like the the attitude
towards the Vietnam War in 1967 you know
from the I mean it's better when we
think of Hollywood now we think of
people that just are you know just
detest everything that has to do with
the military most of the time and you
were kind of in that Hollywood scene
hanging around with all these people but
that didn't rub off on you at all it
didn't happen that way in 67 68 it
wasn't like wasn't like that back then I
was shocked when I got back and I
actually visited Bubba in on Peach
Street in Atlanta Georgia and there was
a anti rally Vietnam rally going down
the street and I looked out the window
and I said Bubba what in the world is
that he says those are anti-war
protestors I'd never seen it never heard
of it
but in 67 everybody was still pretty
patriotic God and didn't have that
situation and and now what about your
old man who was you know he was you were
raised as the son of a guy that was a
b-17 pilot yes a war hero in his self he
was he ran 13 missions he was actually
at first two missions in we're over
Berlin he was on the first two missions
to bomb Berlin itself but he flew 13
missions on his 13th mission they gave
him a brand new airplane because his
airplane had been shot up so bad with
his crew that he brought from the United
States and flew it over to England
that they had to give him a brand new
airplane that morning and he took off
and he had 999 planes behind him he was
point that day and he went over a target
called Schweinfurt as it turned out
schweinfurt in 1444 had lost 56
airplanes and this day his entire
squadron of 22 out of 23 were to be shot
down that day and he was the first one
down and they were using new tactics the
Nazis were when they would line up
Misha Smith's and 109s and in a row and
go right through them instead of coming
around or going on top they just go
right through them they didn't care if
they lost the planes or not and then
they had fought with 190s
behind them and they they took out all
these planes in the very lead just to
start the battle but no one could ever
figure out why schweinfurt was so
protected and so many losses every time
that was tried to be bombed and gehrig
during the Nuremberg trials he admitted
that it was the only ball bearing
factory the Germans owned without ball
bearings a war would have been over
within a matter of a few months and this
whole war went on and on and on because
neither the British or the US could
figure figure that out and they should
have bobbed it every day as what he said
and they favored the war would have been
over what they would have had to
surrender
but just the quirk in the whole
situation but my dad ended up being my
first airborne person in our family
voluntary and halo and he brought
himself what altitude would they find
out ten thousand feet when he jumped
because his plane caught on fire and
they couldn't extinguish it his engines
were on fire and he couldn't open the
bomb bay doors the hydraulic system had
been shot up he'd lost his radio
operator had a 20 millimeter right
through his stomach
had to put a parachute on him and just
shove him out the the bottom door and it
was pretty pretty hectic plane blew up
in midair but those that could got out
and made the free fall to the ground and
pulled their chutes and anyway my dad
was attacked by farmers with pitchforks
and thank God the Gestapo and SS were
there to retrieve him and push the
farmers back he thought he was gonna die
right there in the hole he sprained his
ankle and he was kind of out of it and
but anyway they hauled him off and
strung him up and tried to make him talk
and you know the usual serial number
name and rank and then they put him in
Stalag one which was an all officer camp
had 15,000 officers that had been shot
down in that camp all day listening Minh
went to enlisted stocks and he served 13
months in the powa camp and then one
morning they woke up and the Russians
were there the Russians liberated him
and he was taken home and that's the
story and and he became well known for
in our town for what he did plus he had
two brothers and my uncle Armand was
given a Silver Star by Patton General
Patton himself in France pinned on his
chest and my Uncle Eddie flew Corsairs
so the Letourneau brothers were quite
active yes there were so I had a lot to
follow yeah you did Jesus so I read
vidiots there and I Iran 13 missions
how ironic right that is ran 13 missions
and one bright light when your dad came
home what did he do when did he get out
of the army did he well his Army Air
Corps in those days it wasn't the Air
Force and so he he he tried doing a
little bartending and
this a little that but he had been in
construction he actually was partnered
up with this my grandfather like my
Grandpere
and it was Letourneau and Letourneau
construction company and he filtered
back into the construction and started
building because they needed homes every
all these soldiers coming home and he
built most of Burbank Glendale at the
time and that did he always did quite
well and got into commercial buildings
and and I sort of followed into those
footsteps eventually after I got back
from the service so when you when you
enlisted what did you how did your dad
feel about that well he was not happy
about it because he only gave him a
day's notice
I said I'm going I'm going into the
service and I'm gonna go to Vietnam and
I'm gonna be a green beret but of course
when we and I enlisted they couldn't
give me that it was the only MOS that
they could not give because it wasn't
guaranteed they could guarantee me
anything else they wanted me to be an
officer because I had a degree and I
said no I'm not going to go to OCS I
want to I want to go and be whatever it
takes to be in Special Forces as it
turned out in the long run whether you
really want to hear the whole story
it's up to you but I did end up being a
green beret and going through all the
processes and going through all the
volunteer and being accepted and going
into it and I'm past it but during that
time I'm you have to realize I'm just an
e2 I went in as an e1 I'm an e2 I'm the
lowest ranking there is and the MOS that
I actually graduated with was a prized
MOS that only a few would maintain and
that was heavy weapons they go you can't
be heavy weapons unless you're an e5 or
above but when my turn came up to go in
front of the panel my name being an L
that's a made a document
that's why I can say this I was the
first eetu ever to be accepted for
weapons MOS training because I told him
exactly what I had in mind I said come
Monday morning we've already gone
through our phase 1 and I've got my
green beret and I said we need to go
into MLS and I just want Monday I can
start I said when that MOS is done it so
happens phase 2 of graduation exercised
over a year ago out in the field for two
weeks in survival mode I said it will
start immediately the following Monday
and I said and I can be in Vietnam in
the next three months and they looked at
me and said you got it so if you look at
the orders everything can L dizzy there
was a eetu e3 e4 was in my weapons class
because I started something that
couldn't be turned back tied and turned
so when I got to Vietnam and my first
assignment to F will be one I'm now a
PFC III and Pat Watkins who has the DSC
Distinguished Service Cross from his
time in August 23rd when the FO before
was attacked he told everybody there
must be one bad son of a bitch coming up
here because he's a PFC he's 11 charlie
s SF he said he's been busted down so
far he's got to be that bad a soldier
working on the land and when I showed up
and he looked at me he goes you are a
PFC greenest grass and knew nothing just
been trained darn that's a good that's a
good way to kick it off man
yeah well when F will be one yeah yeah
what did you when you're going through
the check how long was the how long was
the block of training that you so you go
through boot camp how long was the SF
training was that total well I had to go
through boot camp and that
where I had to volunteer to even be go
through the acceptance of trying to be a
sign to SF training then I went into
advanced AIT which is advanced infantry
training you had to go through that and
you also had to sign up for Airborne
training so you had to go through all
all the basics and come out as an 11 b
which was a small infantry arms so
anyway then jump yeah jump school but I
went through that the nomination part of
it taking tests and physical tests and
swimming everything and then interviews
with the SF guys that were there that
were in charge of selecting who was
going to go we started out with 350 men
volunteering to go through this
acceptance they only took 35 and the end
of the deal I was one of the 35 or I
went on to airborne school the next day
and went through jump school at Fort
Benning Georgia they put us after our
last jump which was out of the old
Bhaskar 119 s and then they came in with
the new jets and so I I'm kind of proud
of that and we went on a bus that night
all the way to Fort Bragg and got there
in the early morning hours of Saturday
Saturday morning and then Monday morning
we were in formation for very first day
of training in in Special Forces
and now that block there was two weeks
out on survival phase one then eight
weeks of training after that and then
another two weeks of our graduation
exercises where we're trained to
overtake a government that's what
Special Forces does is actually over
takeover governments and trained
guerrillas to do so and so then 30 days
later I was in Vietnam was the oh I'm
sure the focus must've been like a
hundred percent on hey you're going to
Vietnam we know you're going to Vietnam
this is what its gonna be like this is
what you're dealing with when I
graduated the colonel stood in front of
us ahead of all of trading group and
said I don't want a one of you to
volunteer for fifth group Vietnam we
spent too much money on you you're just
gonna go there and die you stay here
pick any other group I'm gonna go down
the line with the command sergeant major
and he's gonna tell me what group you
want to go to I had 23 graduates in my
class all but three volunteered from
Vietnam he was not happy what I yeah you
think like why does why is someone
during the Vietnam War gonna join
Special Forces unless they want to go to
Vietnam I mean exactly
but in my mind there was something wrong
it had been going on for years
mmm-hmm and Special Forces had been
there before it was a bit a war advising
and I just could not figure that out and
I said I've got to go I've got to see
why it's taken so long it's taking
longer than the World War two and that
was five years so why is it taking so
dang long so I said I've got to get
there and do something about it that's
how I attitude was Frenchman's come he's
gonna handle this thing see oh I see
yeah yeah alright I'm gonna go to the
book here going this is going back to
across the fence and obviously I told
everyone to buy this because I've been
reading chunks of it and if you haven't
bought it yet just buy it right now
written by John Stryker Meyer so this is
a section where he's and he's writing
about the Frenchman so here we go within
24 hours Letourneau and Shore were on
recon teams at fo b1 and they
immediately began training
immediate reaction drills weapons and
explosives training reviewing team SOPs
practicing helicopter extractions on
strings and practicing wiretaps
as october yielded to november many of
the members of the two Recon teams began
to build a rapport because they were
doing so much training together on the
food buy range in addition Letourneau
ensure cook also quickly learned that
the veteran indigenous personnel on
their teams were highly skilled and
fearless warriors one night while
Letourneau was recording a verbal
message for his parents on his portable
cassette player lap the young point man
on st virginia came into his room and
spoken to the recorder i want to tell
you parents of private Letourneau not to
worry about him we respect him and I'll
keep an eye out for him and don't worry
if an enemy shoots at him I'll catch the
bullets with my body
I'll protect your son thank you for
sending it him to Vietnam he's a good
soldier daddy was the kid was like 16
years old and he was our point man who
knows how many kills he had he was
fearless his parents had been both
killed
he was an adoptee in the song he was
raised and lived and fought in SOG Wow
and he prided himself on trying to learn
how to speak English because he wanted
to be number one interpreter yeah how'd
your parents like that did they ever get
the tape they got the tape yeah I wish I
knew where they were but they passed
away and we couldn't find him but yeah
he it was amazing and my dad knew right
then and there I wasn't coming home he
knew I wasn't coming home and he didn't
he had to try to keep my mother from
figuring that out but he knew that I
would not be left come home because of
the secret missions he figured they
would the government would take me out
before they would let me come home with
what I knew and lap was the kind of
Vietnamese South media's ally that you
never heard about mmm that we worked
with every day and we're alive today
thanks to them mm-hmm
our lives to them oh yeah we do and a
couple can be pilots yeah it's true
distractions I have 13 string
extractions 13 for 13 yes lucky 13 I
know it's a bad dad said he had 1,300
bombing hours flight hours but he also
had 13 months in the powa and he was
also shot down on Friday the 13th April
13th April April 13th no superstition
here are Nazis alright continuing on a
few days before Thanksgiving St
Virginia's 1 0 Childress announced that
an operation ordered come down from the
s3 the team had a mission in the western
section of the DMZ and then I'm gonna
fast-forward a little bit here to a guy
named McGovern quiet spoken McGovern
gave him a wry smile and said we can't
have that you need to have a car 15 for
your first mission
follow me the dual walked over to
McGovern's room
he opened his locker and pulled out a
clean car 15 and handed it to Letourneau
this is a special car 15 he said
according to official army records this
car 15 was written off as a combat loss
at fo b3 and Khe Sahn meaning as far as
the army is concerned this weapon
doesn't exist someday after successful
tour of duty in Vietnam if you're so
inclined you can take this baby home
with you because it doesn't exist but as
you can see it does and it's a sweet
weapon it never failed me and I know
that since you're a weapons man you'll
take good care of it
up to this point Letourneau had used an
m16 for all of this training now with
his car 15 he was ready to take on the
world
true there was a mean weapon you see it
in that picture
yeah yeah look has the picture of it
yeah
the and just just rockin those 20 round
mags I every time I see those pictures
of you guys with those 20 round mags I
just I was
Carrie I carried 25 of them stuffed into
the canteen covers we didn't carry food
per se all my food I had zippers sewed
into my sleeves up on my shoulders left
and right and I would roll up dry
dehydrated rice with electrical tape
instead of one full ration I took one
full ration of food and cut it into five
different days from maximum output and
we only ate once a day and we just put
we only had four quarts of water because
we didn't want to carry any more weight
or any more anything else but ammunition
we carried all ammunition grenades m79
shells because we carried sawed-off m79
and so that's all we carried was
ammunition because when we go in that's
our supply
there's no resupply it's all up to us
and many a time we came back with
nothing mmm and had to resupply
ourselves because we got down to the
last bullet many times 25 it was your
load you know much you load outweighed
yes my web gear with all the clips and
everything in it and on the water all
that weighed 75 pounds my rut sack
because I carried the radio the PRC 25
c-4 claymores blasting caps on
everything that you needed an extra
antenna all that stuff inside was
another 75 pounds I weighed 130 5 I
carried 150 pounds into the field
yeah that's crazy that's that's crazy
but thousands everybody's load the in
ditch are mercenaries they carried
probably a hundred and thirty pounds and
they probably didn't weigh more than 120
115 this continuing on the opportunity
arrived on Thanksgiving Day 1968 after
the weather cleared at the kua try
launch site Quang Tri is that right
calling tree Quang tree launch site SD
Virginia boarded the king bees and
headed west to the target area with
three American and four South Vietnamese
team members lap the 17 year old
hardcore point man who had none many
missions hone is that right yes home the
interpreter Cho the m79 operator and con
cowboy Doan who had fought valiantly
besides Lin and black jr. with st
alabama as the second Sikorski turned
westward 135-pound Letourneau went
through a mental checklist of everything
he was carrying McGovern's car 15 the
PRC 25 FM radio an extra battery for it
a sawed-off m79 m79 grenade launcher a
22 caliber high standard pistol with a
silencer ammunition for all weapons hand
grenades gas masks smoke grenades a
camera and five special bags of
dehydrated rice he quickly realized he
was carrying more than a hundred pounds
of gear his inner thoughts were jarred
when the door gunner test-fired his
thirty caliber machine gun without
announcing his intention to anyone with
it within a matter of seconds that came
be cut power and began a tight downward
spiral into the LZ where Childress the
lieutenant hone and lap were already
waiting the dizzying downward spiral
ended as the pilot revved the engine and
landed on the LZ Cho exited the h-34
with Letourneau and cowboy following him
into the wood line connecting with the
remaining members of the team the King
be lifted off and the LZ quickly cleared
the target area and then there was
absolute silence
so there's your first your first mission
insert right there my first insert you
talked about it
I haven't record I'm not knowing what
the heck we're doing but we just dropped
out of the sky no way and I mean it was
adrenaline rush but you know I've been
roping tigers and rhinos and I've been
riding bulls and Broncs and you know it
just it just came to me you know but it
but it was I mean I'm here all my
training all that time over a year I'm
here this is it this is the day yeah now
you question whether you're gonna stand
up to it because you know the enemy's
there we didn't go there because it
wasn't we went there because there was a
trail that needed to be followed and
find out who's running that trail the
the door gunner test fire in that 30 Cal
just is a good wake-up call the Laza I'm
sitting in the door it is right over my
head but cotton and not only that our
King bees were so stripped that they
were so light compared to the regular
h-34 marine ships they could out fly him
in height and we could get up and over
into those mountains and those high
ranges and stuff and but they dripped
oil and they had oil going down your
neck at a time and then when he shot
that 30 caliber to top me the hot brass
hit me in the neck you know scared the
crap outta me almost jumped out hey back
to the book the audio contrast was
starlit startling as Letourneau senses
adjusted the quiet he scoped out the LZ
which was in a deep valley between 3
jungled covered mountains gradually
sounds of the jungle resurfaced birds
chirping bugs humming after 10 minutes
Childress signaled Letourneau to Radio
Covey with the team ok the insertion was
successful no enemy act
the evident Childress moved the team
toward the first Mountain movement was
slowed by tall elephant grass and the
only communication between the team
members was hand signals the team moved
in 10-minute intervals stopping every 10
minutes to listen to what was going on
around it after more than an hour the
team finally emerged from the elephant
grass as it continued to climb the first
mountain Letourneau was on hyper alert
his heart pounding hard whether sitting
in a long rest period or moving up the
mountain near the top of the mountain
lap pointed out an observation platform
that had been cut to the jungle high off
the ground from that platform anyone
could observe the LZ and the valley
where the team was inserted as well as
the other open areas that could be used
for landing helicopters had a trail
watcher been sitting on the platform
when st virginia flew into the LZ if so
where was he headed and when with the
NVA hit the team late in the day the
team finally reached the top of the
mountain and found a wide well-used
trail litter nose first thought was how
could anyone be out here in the middle
of this in the middle of nowhere in this
thick jungle regardless the team set up
its night perimeter far above the trail
where it could see anyone moving while
remaining camouflage and out of sight at
last light Childress made the final
Comeau Jack with Covey as the team
settled in for its first night in the
jungle there was an uneventful night
Childress did a midnight Comeau check
with Hillsboro the night command
aircraft that flew high above the Ho Chi
Minh Trail and the DMZ and checked in
with Covey in the early morning after
the team ate breakfast and shifts
Childress directed lap to move parallel
to the trail with cowboy as a tail
gunner in the line of march and
Letourneau walking in front of cowboy
the team moved slowly in less than 10
minute intervals before taking breaks to
listen to the surrounding sounds they
did this because moving next to the
trail was fraught with inherent risks so
there's your first night out in the
jungle yeah
relatively mellow it was but the
mosquitoes were huge and we were curve
at surround our
we actually used those four tourniquets
as more as we could pull them down over
our ears and face throughout it and pick
those mosquitos out the next day cuz
they were like cranes and I mean then
you have to realize - that's the first
meal for an entire day with 100 day 100
degree weather and only one quart of
water a sip in the morning a sip at noon
a little bit for the dehydrated rice at
night and a sip this wash it down with
them there's one quart gone for the day
it couldn't allow yourself to drink ever
except on those intervals and you didn't
you didn't did you guys plan to resupply
water like did you guys look at the maps
and see melt sea rivers or anything no
streams no nothing so you planted one
quart a day one quart a day we figure
out it's not healthy I know you're I
know you're a trainer but that's what we
had to allow ourself there because of
the weight you know a gallon of water
7.5 it is so we had to judge our weight
of versus ammunition and we that's what
we trained ourselves to do and not only
that we also took pills so that we
wouldn't go to the bathroom either hmm
because they could smell you I'm
smelling American that's why we had to
eat rice and eat everything they ate
otherwise they'd smell you know MRIs and
and can't see rations all that stuff
they could smell that for miles and they
had trackers out there and you had to
watch for those which I think you'll get
to but just that water ration is what
you have I trained myself for a year to
do that I I did that all the time
because we figured we'd be out in the
sixth day we'd come out in the sixth day
so we'd have no water on the last day
but we can survive the five days did you
ever take any casualties guys that went
down from lack of water
actually never did that's amazing in the
desert we would even a training guys
we'd have guys go down like on a on a
two-day operation I'd have guys go down
from lack of water I've had guys go down
in training in the stateside mm-hmm but
I never had any our guys we would I'm
just gonna say we were talking well it
jungle is a little different in the
desert too yeah yeah and because you're
got shade yeah your your triple canopy
so you actually are got shade under
Nover the tapia you're not in open areas
you never go in an open area you always
follow the canopy but you have to move
slowly because it's so darn thick so it
takes time and you have the tail Gunners
job is to cover the trail mm-hmm
try to put if you everybody walks in
everybody's footprint if you try that's
what you're supposed to do everybody has
a an area to cover one guy turns to the
right and the other guy turns to the
left the point man covers the 180 in
front tail got it causes a 180 in back
and we train like that we don't turn our
backs and look it's what the other guy
is doing
we only concentrate on our area and keep
that area clean unless we have to move
in that direction then we all turn that
way and move mm-hmm it's a precision
it's a precision movement that we
practice we train like that every time
we were back in camp we trained how to
move that's why our T Virginia and our T
Idaho or survivable teams
besides the having the luck of the Gods
with us mm-hmm you know sometimes you
got to make your own luck a little bit
through and you know we we talk about
that all the time like we would train
all the time we'd patrol around in the
compound rehearse rehearse we'd rehearse
get this is only shocks people versus
getting that in and out of the trucks
like you know we'd have a big a big
giant truck to transport troops in but
we do raids with those things and we
practice getting out you know like okay
because if this takes you seven seconds
if you're in a firefight I mean seven
sex sis you've law a long time to be
trying to get out of a truck that people
are
launching grenades at you know and so
we'd practice that we could do it
quickly do it at night do it in the dark
do it with your gear on
you know reverse order do it again and
that's what we do so that we'd be you
know ready we for those six we did the
same thing we actually working on a
vessel before we had a island called
monkey Mountain and we'd go over there
and we set up a course to walk from one
side to the other and that's how we were
trained so that we we could continually
upgrade how we walked
and you guys didn't I've talked to tilt
about this you guys didn't bring
mosquito nets in a field to wear over
your head never that would be what we
had was what they called believe it or
not they had mosquito repellent that was
US Army issue but we also had Max Factor
that did the makeup okay what's that all
about the greasepaint camouflage paint
oh yeah and what we'd would do is take
the repellent and mix it in our palms
squirt it into our palms and put the
grease paint in our palms and then put
the paint over our face or to cover our
highlights so there's no reflections and
besides that I used electrical tape and
wrapped up my my trousers at the bottom
around my my boots so to keep the
leeches out but also that closed off and
then I also did that around the wrists
of my arms and then we wore
we our car 15s are so hot that we had to
wear gloves with a few fingers cut out
among them we looked like Michael
Jackson way before his time I wish you
talking about that grease paint ID I
like that there you go a little late the
leaf base or no mosquito repellent and
the grease paint mixed together made a
very gooey mess but it would keep them
off of your face you know and when you
were at night when they were at their
worst you could pull that Corvette
and then you know keep him out of your
ears and they would stay off your face
because they didn't want anything to do
with it and we always carry just a
little extra with us to keep it going
you know because being out there for
five days you know the most that most
that I mean most of the time we get shot
out in the day two days three days but I
had the luck of having several five and
seven day missions I was able to stay
out a long time as our teams progressed
further and deeper they didn't think
we'd go that far but we went deeper than
anybody could ever go we got down to
some of our missions and layoffs with
one minute on time with the king bee
there was no bringing us out once they
dropped us on the ground it was over
with they had to go back and get fuel so
no 10 minute station time they just
dropped your left add to add to but they
weren't expecting us that far we could
get right in to catch him off guard
all right going back to the book has st
virginia moved up ii mountain cowboy and
Letourneau began to hear women's voices
off the trail cowboy urged Letourneau to
go explore the sounds Letourneau shook
his head no indicating they had to stay
with the team cowboy who spoke broken
English repeated the suggestion adding
it could be a small NVA village we could
kill everyone and make the NVA beaucoup
angry we want to let them know we can
hurt them the same way they attack our
camps and villages let's her note again
declined and gave him the hand signal to
plant some m14 anti-personnel mines on
the trail behind them in case the NVA
soldiers were trailing them as the team
moved on Letourneau planted a few more
toe poppers and marked their locations
on his map for after covering them
expertly he laid down some powdered
mustard gas on the ground for any
tracker dogs that might follow their
trail the mustard gas was left over from
World War one how it landed at Phu Bai
remained a mystery to Letourneau the
good news it was that it still worked
the fact that it was the fact was
confirmed during the next break when the
team heard a dog howl in anguish after
snorting some of the old mustard gas
maybe it didn't work that well because a
few minutes later the dog was back on
the teams trail cowboy told the terno to
use his pistol to kill the dog litter
nose mine flashed back to Special Forces
training group our instructors had said
the same thing
Letourneau pulled out the 22 quietly
moved back down the trail took off his
rock rucksack and moved a few more feet
before lying down on the ground facing
the trail the dog never realized the
turno was there when the dog was about
ten feet away Letourneau fired one shot
it struck the dog between the eyes
killing him instantly the canine dropped
in his tracks out a litter nose view
unaware of what had happened the dog's
handler moved up the trail he got near
the dead dog when he got near the dead
dog he stepped on a toe popper
Letourneau and cowboy heard the NVA
screaming in pain and anguish they left
him behind figuring he would die shortly
the team moved further up the mountain
with Letourneau and cowboy providing
rear security again
turn oh and cowboy we heard women's
voices below them again cowboy urged the
Letourneau to go downhill and attack the
encampment and again Letourneau declined
that's so that's so these guys are on
you obviously at this point when when
you are you guys are still heading up
the mountain because but but do you
think you can get away from them and
what is your point what is your what is
your what are you trying to accomplish
at this point at this point we're trying
to get away from the tracker well I
managed to take care of the tractor but
we don't know how many people are there
we keep hearing the voices of women's
voices below us cowboy keeps wanting me
to go down there with him trying to
confuse the whole situation because he
wants to kill him
because he says it'll make a mad then
he'll come after us and they can really
get into it well cowboy just got off a
mission on October 5th which is in the
book where they decimated a 10,000 man
division of all things eight and a half
hours they took down 85% of them with an
eight-man team incredible but it's true
you know they stack bodies up for
sandbags that's how many they were
killing so fast but he was insistent but
I told him we can't do that because I
can't split the team I have to do it my
one zero says I'm I'm just a one two ha
ha I'm unload man on the totem pole here
you know there's even a lieutenant with
us but he's he's the one one he's bullet
he's actually below my sergeant because
there's no rank in song that was one of
the things that that always took me back
was there was no rankings and song we
didn't carry rank we didn't wear rank is
whoever was there the longest that lived
the longest was the tenth head man he's
the one zero who ever lived the longest
was the one zero and that's how it went
down and then when that one zero was
killed the one one took over and usually
took over the team from there on until
he was killed and then the next one the
one two would take over he because he'd
stepped up to the one one position and
that's how we progressed
our teams because everybody was killed
one as as it as we went along we were
just lucky but I did lose my one zero
Gunther wall and course Childress went
home and he was lost to an automobile
accident and so it's just you know but
that's how they progressed it and at
this point this is your first mission
you got a it's like I'm trying to do
everything right yeah and you're getting
the full benefit on your first mission
you got the dog track of you you've got
the the NVA encampment down below you
got the women's voices you got the
tracker coming up behind the dog I mean
it's the he's hitting the toe popper
this is like and we know you know
everything everything you were hoping
for here it is and we know the NVA is
there because the jungle baby because
the families are there so we know of
course we're on we're thinking - maybe
they they're the trackers families - you
know because they would hire trackers
they tell the trackers you either track
for us we'll kill you and so they have
no choices but because they're just
ended out there living trying to survive
so you're trying to get up the mountain
get away from the tracker was it
possible to shake the trackers was it
possible to like actually lose him
sometimes sometimes or did you feel like
once the trackers were on you you were
pretty much heading to your extract
exactly exactly because they were they
were communicating in some way of
fashion to let the NVA know we fought
regular troops we never shot fought the
Vietcong that they call the VC we we
actually fought uniformed NVA and the
Regular Army mm-hmm the North Vietnamese
had but we needed to get off of that
keep off the trail and keep going
because we needed to find out where this
trail was going this was our mission to
try to figure out where this trail went
it we did accomplish it in the end
because I went on a second mission just
later in the
book and I found actually went into
North Vietnam and was inserted on
Christmas of 68 in North Vietnam on the
same trail but higher up and that's a
whole different story there but we're
going back to this story here we go by
the time Letourneau completed his last
radio call to Covey the team was
enveloped in darkness and team members
began to set up a perimeter for the
night dawn broke without any enemy
activity with Covey flew over the team
in the morning
he warned Childress that a team was
being extracted extracted under heavy
fire and another was being inserted into
a top priority target sit tight was the
last instruction from Covey st virginia
didn't move from its quiet spot
alongside the mountain during lunch hour
the member each member ate in shifts and
Letourneau went out to inspect the
claymore mines the team had deployed to
ensure the NVA hadn't turned the deadly
explosive devices around to face toward
them when he completed his inspection
Letourneau found a log to sit behind the
NVA would actually do that they'd crawl
up to your perimeter and turn your claim
triple-canopy you don't you could pass
them up within two feet of you they
could be two feet away from me and you
wouldn't know it that's how thick the
jungle is and you would see a foot you
know you think combat you might see a
foot and you shoot the foot as long as
you shot the foot you know he was down
he wouldn't go to survive they had no
hospitals you know see you could count
that as a as a kill but you know but you
can see you just had to mow down the
jungle
open it up guess where they're at the
green trace is coming out gave you a
clue yeah yeah it's just shocking to me
that they they would crawl up and try
and turn around your claymore mines so
that when you attack when they attacked
you then you clock off your claymores
and boom you're actually claymore in
yourself later on the CIA gave us a
piece of equipment that I carried that
had a little thread out of a box and you
could wrap that whole thread around your
your encampment where you were a Oh is
right at the moment and put it in your
ear and if that's thread was broke it
would sound a buzzing noise in your ear
and you knew somebody came through it
could have been an animal but you knew
somebody came through your perimeter and
you just had to put it in front of all
your claymores and then to stop it you
just lit a match and burned it you used
the next day the next time but once you
I had that my my perimeters were always
covered going back to the book later in
the afternoon Childress signaled the
team to pull in their claymore mines and
prepare to move out due to the combined
weight of his rucksack and web gear
Letourneau moved to his knees and slung
his rucksack on his back just as it
landed on his back ache a forty-sevens
opened fire Letourneau was slammed to
the ground face-first the impact so
severe he thought he had broken his nose
startled Letourneau jumped up with his
car 15 pointing toward the ak-47 gunfire
that was near the front of the team
surprised that there was no NVA near him
Letourneau removed the rucksack to
discover that four ak-47 rounds had
ripped through the 23 pound PRC 25 he
reached into an especially especially
tailored pocket on his fatigue shirt
which was sewn with vertical zippers one
on the left side of the shirt and one on
the right side between the top and
bottom of the pockets of the shirt it
pulled out his URC 10 emergency radio
and broadcast a general alert for any
aircraft in the area st virginia was
declaring a prairie fire emergency so
this is that your first fire from the
enemy he could shop the radio for four
rounds in the radio knock you down yeah
I didn't know nothing all I knew and my
button nose was busted I thought it was
anyway and and I'm going and I'm having
to think what am I supposed to do and I
my it was my first reaction meanwhile my
1-0 Childress was mad as hell at me
because he says bring me that damn radio
that hurt a ting could do crap for us he
said I said any work and I think it's
shot up and I said it don't work there's
no signal and so I brought it to him
well needles are saying I was standing
up when I brought it to him and he's
laying on the ground and he grabs me he
says can't you just get down
well the ak-47 rounds are hitting all
over us we're in the middle of a
firefight artwork returning fire me I'm
still standing there in shock and he
pulls me to the ground saves my life and
he says he looks at the radio real quick
and he goes the antennas been shot off
that was the fifth round mm-hmm that
went through it I reached between my
nutsack and my Webb gear and pulled out
my spare antenna and screwed it on and
we had , that radio was good to go
that's air-conditioned and we just then
Pat Watkins is flying over our comfy
rider and he called
whee-hee-hee assess what was going on he
could see it from where his location was
in the air and he could see he could see
we were taking massive amounts of fire
and he called for an extraction from
Quang tree and they they brought the
king bees in to get us we had yeah yeah
the once he got that once he got once he
got the radio back for you to started
working children screams into the radio
we need an exfil now I'm declaring
prairie fire emergency is anyone out
there within a second or two there was a
response calm down Childress I realize
you're under fire said a co V rider just
at that moment several ak-47s opened up
from the wood line near the log where
Letourneau had been unceremoniously
slammed onto his face lap and cowboy
returned fire Covey Rider continued we
heard your team declare a prairie fire
emergency on the guard frequency and
have rallied the cavalry what's your
mark do you have an LZ in sight before
Childress said a word in the radio he
turned to Letourneau and said see it
suppose we have left it for the envier
never I say never ever leave a radio
behind as if to emphasize that point the
NVA opened fire again as a lap took as
that began looking for an LZ while
moving the team down the hill away from
the most concentrated NVA gunfire
cutting litter no no slack Childress
roared tell Covey we'll give him a fix
in five minutes we'll probably need
strings to get out of here I doubt we
can make it into the valley where it can
be king bee can pick us up without
missing a beat
litter know who for the first time felt
for burning stings in his back repeated
those words to Covey while he and Kowboy
began providing cover fire as the tail
element of the team then Letourneau
nodded a cowboy who ignited several
claymore mines that the team had set out
on this perimeter those mines only sold
the NVA for a few seconds before the
dust and debris from the blast settled
the NVA soldiers were moving through it
toward cowboy and Letourneau without
saying a word the two men took turns
firing at the enemy while moving down
the hill rotating around each other
cowboy would fire several bursts from
his car fifteen and then reload as he
reloaded letona would open fire
providing cover for covering fire for
the team the classic cover and move
scenario yes
just the way we drill it that's right oh
yeah and it just came natural believe it
or not it just came natural what part of
it just came natural just load and fire
lower higher and move load and fire move
load and fire and that just we had to
get and the team came together our
firepower you can only imagine what a
full team of firepower with all car 15s
and m79 s and claymore mines going off
they knew they had a battle but they
were overpowering us yeah
it's about this with tilt as well like
the determination of of them where you
think of the insurgents insurgent army
you know their rule is like a we don't
we don't need to fight we don't need to
win this firefight we don't need to win
this battle cuz we're gonna be here for
a long time we can wait we will fight
when we want to fight and it's the way
that they attacked you
and law took so many losses but to
continued to press and continue to press
like their their fighting spirit was
high well let me give you a backdrop on
that maybe tilt hasn't even got to that
after the war is over with and history
starts evolving in the books and people
start asking questions we find out that
they've got 40,000 troops hunting this
down
hunting sagres down and there's a huge
bounty on us we heard a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand dollars to kill an
American I'm on a song team and they had
to kill an American award if they kill
somebody they got the award and a bonus
mm-hmm and they were instant heroes in
Hanoi forever it meant everything to
them to kill us and they put 40,000
troops designated that we had tied up
because they wanted to kill us because
we did so much damage to go ahead yeah
speaking of damage during one short law
cowboy again planting two claymore mine
in the direction of the advancing NVA in
Letourneau dug out another Claymore from
his rucksack and placed a 10-second
delay fuse in it when the NVA again
advanced cowboy ignited his claymore
mind claymore mine when the NVA moved
again toward the team Letourneau ignited
his fuse and ran down the hill with
cowboy to catch up to their team before
they reached the team to be 40
anti-personnel rockets slammed into the
trees above them showering them with
shrapnel a few more exploded as
Letourneau and cowboy moved down the
hill the 10 second then the 10 second
fuse ignited in another Claymore it
brought it bought precious time for the
gun and run team of Letourneau and
cowboy to cover ground and catch up with
a remainder of st virginia would you
guys drill pulling out those claymores
with the tents that confused and hooking
them up and setting them up I mean you
know it takes like a little bit of time
to do that did you guys have them
pre-rigged where you could just stick
them in the ground how did you guys do
that we did we had them pre-rigged
everybody says well you can't have your
blast
caps with you you're just they hit the
blast guys she's gonna blow you to
smithereens yeah but those precious
seconds with me and I had mine in my nut
sack pre-rigged
there you go yeah with us but Bubba had
his pre-cut so we had to five-second ten
seconds and then longer and then you had
axle cracker itself with the full
standard cord that you could blow it
they would give you more distant how
long was that core 50 feet 50 feet and
so you could put the claim word down on
the tree and pull back and then you hit
it the handheld yeah Lorelei's we did
and I'm one mission we were using the
five seconds that Bubba put in but they
were pre-cut we had them ready to go so
you just put the fuse in and pull it and
stick it in the ground yeah the little
stakes standard for stakes yeah boom
jamming in the ground and you're good
yeah so you're setting those things up
in like 10 seconds she always had to
make sure they're pointed the right way
yes indeed I point towards the end run
towards enemy yeah continue on as
Childress called an air strikes
Letourneau reflected on how surreal this
firefight had been it wasn't like
anything he'd witnessed on television or
in it in any movie instead of men
charging each other and killing each
other in plain sight here in
triple-canopy jungle he observed Green
tracers from ak-47s first or at the most
an enemy hand or foot and somehow the
NVA found firing lanes where they could
launch shoulder held be 40
anti-personnel rockets that slammed
above and around them as they raced down
the hill for their lives again the end
they voices of the Special Forces
instructors echoed in his mind they had
told the young aspiring Green Berets at
Fort Bragg that the NVA was a tough
resilient opponent many had fought
against the Japanese during World War
two and against the French driving them
from Vietnam in 1954 after the Battle of
Denby MTU in North Vietnam the sounds of
King bees in the distance and the
crashing Thunder of b40 rocket slamming
into trees above his head shook
Letourneau out of his moment of
introspection and turned his undivided
attention to a crescendo of ak-47 fire
from the enemy
SD Virginia responded with volley after
volley a full and semi automatic gunfire
while Letourneau and Cho fired several
m79 rounds toward the densest section of
the jungle where the ak-47 gunfire was
emanating through the gunfire someone
popped a smoke grenade which brought the
King bees closer to arty Virginia's
location in the jungle over the din of
gunfire childress and cowboy told
everyone to put their swiss seats on and
prepare for an extraction
in short order a king bee was hovering
over st virginia more than 125 feet
above the jungle floor Letourneau cowboy
chow and hone hook their D rings into
the old McGuire rig that hung from the
end of the ropes and shortly were being
lifted out of the jungle as the quartet
of recon men was being lifted into the
air the envy on the NVA Unleashed
another salvo of ak-47 gunfire and
several b40 rockets shrapnel from the
rockets hit them with varying degrees of
size and velocity all of them were
wounded it was during those explosions
that Letourneau realized his car 15 and
somehow been caught in a rope above him
just far enough away that he couldn't
reach it he pulled out his m79 and
launched a 40-millimeter grenade toward
the NVA positions now all he could see
of the enemy were hundreds of muzzle
blast from ak-47s and green tracers
Green tracer rounds eerily climbing
toward the quartet of st virginia men
before he could reload his m79 the king
bee began to move away from the target
area surprising him because the men had
not yet cleared the jungle instead of
continuing to climb out of the target
moving straight up until the men cleared
the jungles triple canopy of trees and
vegetation the king bee was moving away
from the target area due to heavy enemy
ground fire in recent months at least
two King bees were shot down during
string extractions from hot targets but
these facts were unknown to Letourneau
at the time shrapnel from the b40 rocket
exploded around st virginia men stinging
them with bits of hot metal further
spooking the king bee crew Letourneau
began to violently collide with tall
jungle trees feeling like a metal ball
in a pinball machine litter noka room
doff several more trees as Atlee
one more b40 exploded in the treetops
again showering him with shrapnel a tree
branch hit Letourneau from the side and
turned him upside down in his in his
robe swiss seat as the Rope began to
slip down from his hips Letourneau
remembered spider telling him how a one
zero from another team had recently been
shot out of his Swiss seat during a rope
extraction another tree struck
Letourneau before he was able to muster
a surge of strength and momentum to
reach up and grab the rope above him as
his body finally cleared the treetops
the only thing between him and certain
death below on the jungle floor 200 feet
down was the single piece of rope tied
into the king bee gees just another day
and saw just another day in SOG huh and
I had 13 of those like that how did you
guys when you're getting hit with all
that and you're shooting back hanging
from a string I mean that's just like
completely insane that that no one died
on that on that rope on that extraction
and you're also spinning just the
rotation now hop down get knocked around
the strings just spinning and the air is
flowing past you and you're having you
know you're just trying everything you
do to stick with it but that was my
first mission later on I've finally
realized that I didn't have an extra
d-ring on my web gear to strap in that's
why I was falling over backwards I did
that twice then I finally found out from
my good buddy here til that I was doing
it wrong because after my second mission
childress had left but he had not given
me that information out of all of our
training I had not thought about it he
was extracted on another job so he
didn't see that happen
this just it's it's unbelievable when I
when I read these things I just can't
it's just hard to even fathom the the
mayhem when you're talking about just
all these b40 rockets which is basically
like an RPG it's an older hour RPG it's
crazy going back to the book with one
final urgent poll eternal was able to
move himself upright in the Swiss seat
as the king be continued to climb higher
into the sky distance distancing itself
from the fear of exploding v40 an ak-47
gunfire while gaining airspeed as the
king bee ascended the heavily sweating
Letourneau clung to the rope as another
sensation overwhelmed his body
chattering teeth within a matter of
minutes that king bee had climbed to an
altitude of more than 5,000 feet where
the air is thinner and much much colder
than on the jungle floor so much colder
that litter nose body began shaking
violently from the dipping temperatures
as the king bee continued to climb into
the safety of higher altitude in
ordinary circumstances few people would
ever think about freezing to death over
Southeast Asia but for the men in C&C it
was just another hurdle they had to
clear as the king beheaded East will
eternal look down on the spots in the
jungle that appeared to be good L Z's
thinking why don't you land there
but st virginia's collective agony
continued until the King bees finally
landed in South Vietnam by that time
every member of st st virginia had their
circulation cut off to their legs they
couldn't stand or walk all they could do
is unhook from their Swiss seat grab
their stuff and try and get the
circulation going again in their legs
while the door gunner helped them to get
back to the king bee when the team
returned to Quang Tri Quang tree long
tree launch site before heading south to
Phu Bai Childress pulled Letourneau
aside and told him take good care of
that radio you're gonna take it on the
next mission whether you like it or not
was he gonna make you bring the shot up
radio yeah he did we did it saved his
life
tilts life in the end how's that that
Christmas Day mission okay
we had the Intel report was that the
same radio yeah you brought a shot up
radio and defeated not me
I got a hundred-mile skip out of it
that's ridiculous
as darkness fell that King bees lifted
off from quang tree for flew by when the
old warbirds landed on fo b1 landing
zone st Virginia was greeted by one man
former st Virginia one-zero John
McGovern he greeted each of the team
members as they exec sitted the King
bees asking each one are you okay after
the King bees departed bathing them in
sand dust and LZ debris kicked up by the
product propwash McGovern asked
Childress did you hear about Bader a
tall Childress shook his head no what
happened
November 13th we lost a king bee with
seven SF troops on it we lost the entire
King bee crew they were a bunch of
straphangers who volunteered to pull an
elder son mission on the trail but an
anti-aircraft round hit the king bee en
route to the target it exploded in
midair they never had a chance in
silence McGovern drove the tired dirty
and hungry team back to the team room as
the Vietnamese team members climbed off
the truck McGovern turned to Letourneau
and said you know what was really scary
about that mission the day before they
got shot down me Lin black Rick Howard
John Peters Tim Schaaf and a few others
had volunteered and were actually on the
King B's suited up ready to go only to
be canceled last minute by bad whiskey
x-ray which is weather in the AL that
was too close for comfort after a long
pause pause Letourneau
he asked Letourneau how did it go out
there I heard you were good on the radio
you didn't get rattled
you ain't a cheery no more you've joined
a small unique Club of SF men C and C
recon men who went across the fence it
was nothing like I ever could have
imagined litter no responded looking
toward the Vietnamese team members he
added let me get some chow for the in
ditch you were right about them they
have ice in their veins I'm beat I'll
see you in the morning
Letourneau walked through the white sand
to the mess hall picked up some fresh
sandwiches and cold sodas for the team
after lingering with the Vietnamese
team members Letourneau returned to his
room finally taking off his rucksack and
web gear as he started to undress
Letourneau became aware of pain in his
back where from where the four ak-47
rounds had slammed him face-first into
the ground first he peeled off his
jungle fatigued shirt and was amazed to
find four bullet holes in it then he
took off his undershirt ditto for bullet
holes were in it Letourneau picked up
his rucksack four bullet holes were in
it both in the front and the back
something he hadn't realized during the
firefight then he looked in the mirror
and saw four large welts and broken skin
up his spine with the ak-47 rounds had
hit his body after punching through his
rucksack and the PRC twenty five only
then did Letourneau begin to comprehend
just how lucky he had been hours earlier
in the day when the NVA shot him in the
back four times Letourneau began to cut
away the metal the black electrical tape
around his socks which he pulled up over
his pant legs to keep out leeches and
bugs then he made a startling discovery
when he pulled his pant leg from the
sock and pulled off his right boot four
ak-47 bullets fell on the ground in the
heat of the battle the Frenchman didn't
realize that after he was shot in the
back the four 7.62 millimeter NVA rounds
had fallen through his pants and his
socks into his right boot
he stood an utter amazement staring at
the four rounds on the floor before
picking them up and throwing them in the
sand outside his room
exhausted Letourneau walked over to the
shower room the water stung the wounds
in his back amazingly the four bullets
had enough energy to penetrate his skin
wounding him but not enough to get under
his skin too tired to treat the four
bullet wounds in his back and shrapnel
wounds in his arm Letourneau finished
his shower and went to bed
so that that was mission number one
there's a saying that we came to realize
later on everybody just look at you and
say well that's just another day in song
my first mission I had to run 12 more
before it was done and when you got done
with it I mean were you were you talk to
the other guys and they were telling you
hey yeah that's that's how it is
yes that's how it is so you couldn't go
in the into the bar and go there this is
what I did you just said yeah I I got
back well and don't forget the footnote
on that it goes like about about four or
five days later the medics yeah tell
about the wounds from the shrapnel of
course I had to ignore everything
because otherwise they'd all think I was
you know just a Wooper so I just suck it
up not say nothing and but all of a
sudden I started getting these boils on
me they were huge so I went to the medic
and and maggio Louie yeah
Maggio says well he says you got
shrapnel in you buddy that's all that's
all swollen it's infecting you he says
you're gonna have that for quite a while
until we can get every piece out of you
he says I don't know how many holes you
got but this one here needs attention
right now and it's huge and there was a
my arm and forearm actually and he
looked at the other medic shipping and
said hold him down and he looked at me
and said yeah don't you look at what I'm
doing don't you turn your head he said
because otherwise you're gonna pass out
on me
well you see what I'm gonna do he said
so don't you look holding judgment you
hold him down and don't look her glass
out well what he was doing was taking a
big stick swab in hydrogen peroxide and
burning a hole right through the the
boil and then he took forceps
he pulled the strings out with the
shrapnel on the end from the beef 40
Rockets because they're all made you
know in China they're Tchaikovsky no and
so they had a lot of string that's how
they wrapped them they didn't mold up in
the metal like we did and so anyway I
kept having to go and then another day I
had to go in he had to do the back of my
head and I had a couple in my head and
then I had a couple in my back and
another under my arm and I walked around
with bandages until I went out on my
next mission I gotta tell you I
witnessed one of those getting pulled
out and it was gross what were you doing
just wanted to do swell they he had
pulled several out
well I you talked about the pus but hey
where you gonna go back in the field
anyways yeah it was like hey it doesn't
matter we'll do we'll do what we can
right now
what makes that exact the field exactly
because we had another mission lined out
for Christmas of 68 so what was the op
tempo like meaning how often would you
when you did you did your 13 missions
how long did that take
what timespan was that over well then
one-year tour one-year tour I had 13
missions and one bright light and
someday we'll talk about the bright
light I guess why not today you know
it's a it's a it's not written in the
books because of what it ended up being
but a bright light and SOG is a
volunteer situation where a team will
volunteer to go in and get another team
out that's okay can't get out and we had
a lot of those or to try to find a team
that disappeared and we had a lot of
teams disappear
IRT Idaho Lane and Owens completely
disappeared they've never been found to
this day no trace just completely off
the map people have gone into this day
and hunt the government hunts today and
can't find them under good circumstances
are these the guys that you took over
for yes yes
you know and so when I got on the
Idahoans transferred from Virginia to
Idaho because tilt went home and I
became Lynn blacks 101
one day he had been gone for a while up
at headquarters and I I always protected
him because I'm the one one I protected
my one zeros I had to know where they
were don't do it all the time because
you just never knew because we had we
had nuns we had cam boats we had
mountain yards and we had Vietnamese in
our camp they all fought amongst
themselves let alone wondering if
they're the enemy and we also had an
entire team of NVA Chu hoist to hoist
being they gave up and that was team
Cobra and they were there for a very
special mission that they went on and to
get us prisoners out of a camp that was
located but we got a call Lin went up to
their headquarters it had been a little
while so I went up there to see what was
going on he's walking back down and says
can we go on a bright light I said we're
ready we're packed cuz that's just what
you did if you were asked you went he
said we got two pilots down and we and
there they we think they're alive we got
to go in they brought a Jolly Green
Giant in for us which is very unusual
Air Force I don't know where they really
took us at this point in time in my life
I'd we still don't know they have all
kinds of records but it's very confusing
of where we went but we came in and that
jolly when we circled over the top of
the plane it was all intact
it was just sitting there in elephant
grass no one could figure out why so
they brought us down and I jumped out
but when I jumped out there was a slight
lift in the plane and in the Jolly Green
and it just came down back down on me
bout crushed me and then it came back up
and then Lin jumped out and my guys
jumped out and each other and it was a
no - what's a push-pull Cessna a engine
in the front and engine in the back
that's what I've been shot down yeah we
think it was shot down
we don't or crash town - - however we
just don't know how it happened but what
the real deal was is the plane
whatever happened to it was making an
emergency landing and he saw this
opening like an LZ and thought this
would be a good place to at least start
the landing even if it went into the
jungle it would slow it down problem was
as soon as they hit the ground there was
a bowl and they hit the front of the
bowl with the front engine and stopped
dead like a burner it was a bird yeah
and it stopped it dead but it bent the
engine around to the right and the man
in the right seat was sucked up into
their carburetors into the like home
engine and he was in the fins and he
just had his head in his arm stick it
out said when I got there on that side
it said ten minutes after 10:00 in the
morning his Rolex watch was cracked the
bezel was cracked and it stopped the
watch 10 after 10:00 and we didn't get
there till about 2:30 well and don't
forget when the choppers going down
you're under fire yeah and it's we're
getting some small arms fire and Lynn
goes to the pilot side on the on the
left side and he looked fine but we
realized the yoke had crushed his chest
and killed him in place but it also had
him trapped and we couldn't get either
one out but at that point in time that
was a trap they had set the Jolly Green
had backed off and we started taking
tremendous amount of a fire I looked
across the inside of the cabin at Lynn
and then looked back at me and I said I
love you brother
not getting out of this and he he said
no we're not
this is it finally got us and I looked
up and radioed the
Jolly Green to come back in and he shook
his head I could see him plain as day he
shook his head I don't think I can come
back I said you better cuz I got an m79
pointed at you I'll take you down with
us he moved up forward by that time
there was 200 MVA surrounding us giving
it everything they got and we managed to
crawl into that chopper because if we
got up on the wings and he scooped us up
and I had already called in attack here
because they already had TAC air ready
and as we lifted off and got up about
fifty feet and they once bad flew right
underneath us between the plane and the
in the chopper
and I he looked up at me like this it
was smiling and he dropped the WP right
on top of them and there was crispy
critters running everywhere and we got
out of there and got back and we walked
down landed us back at fo before and we
walked down the the road back to our
couch and we just looked at each other's
another day and saw and all the time
there on the ground made their under
fire going in
they put a perimeter around the aircraft
while Lynn and Doug went in to try to
establish what the status of the pilots
war and the firefight was intense
Kember when I got back Doug had just
left and I came back to now at the end
of October 69 so that bright lay was
fresh on Lynn's mind he talked about it
and I talked to happen it later about
that Braley and they're going dis was
crazy cuz chef Sally went in before in
ditch from RT I know and that team and
Lynn was like man I don't even know how
we got out of there so as one of
real another just a really tight one but
like Doug says in a way when you now in
retrospect like just another day in SOG
but that wasn't really stuck yeah I just
thought now out of all my missions and
if you read the book and were tilt
honors me with a few missions in his
books between across the fence and on
the ground that one there was as tense
as it got and we thought it was over fit
physically and mentally we gave up we
thought it was over that we just weren't
gonna get up out of that mess and get
into that chopper then b40 rockets were
hitting that plate underneath that Jolly
Green we were going up in the air faster
than the chopper could get us up in the
air from the pounding we were takin that
had been four that's bad we might not
have mm-hmm to this day we can't find
this bad pilot we have reunions we go to
as Maddon readings but we still haven't
been able to find that spam pilot did
that day cuz ways sans like when the
Jolly Green is pulling out the beef
forty pounded underneath and the armor
playing could sustain it and it would
but it give the chopper Jolla Clint
black hat on October 15 this but there
is experiencing again one october year
later same thing exactly yeah i'm
surprised that they take those be forty
strikes like that I mean one lucky shop
that hits the tail rotor or something
analyst game over sure you know when we
get back on missions we walk around our
King B's and count how many bullet holes
and how many were in the blades we do
there's clean shots through the blades
and then we caught 40 50 80 rounds in
our King B's when we come back and
pieces of metal gone that they had to
put tin over they use beer cans yeah
Aluna beer cans yeah
and what about the what about that
operation were you we had to go and get
the 55-gallon drum of and pull that one
over okay well go through that somebody
would probably like to read it in the
book but we'll kind of go through that
we were trained
we had a CIA agent come in and train us
for a brand new explosive detonator
there was a time device they were shaped
on the top end of a bun of a 55-gallon
drum as curls you put a wrench on it and
unscrew it you've seen them and we said
this is by the way this is a seal type
mission so you really appreciate this no
this is absolutely yeah when I read
about it I was like that's a good seal
mission but yeah but oh well well they
didn't let the seals do that in those
days no they were busy on the coast yeah
they were busy on the coast they really
were we under this I mean everything up
to that is in a jungle you get to the
river but exactly but we actually went
into secret lockup couldn't talk to
anybody nobody could come in and talk to
us and we went through these exercises
and training we actually loaded up for
it and they took us out to it and took
us to Hong tree and we launched out of
there and went into layoffs into this
huge river that they had but we had to
stay away from it
we had to actually hike in for two days
to get to it and when we got there and
down the hill and to the river it was
night on the second end of the second
day and then Gunther was my one zero and
I was as one one there was no one one
two and
he was an ex-marine and he was an e6
and he was my one cero he'd been around
a while and he says okay go in and get
that drum and I says well you're the
marine you're Navy why should I go in
you're the one okay you're here the one
one you're a PFC and I'm an e6 so that's
how it's going down well and don't
forget before you get there they hiked
through jungle for two days and two
nights right to meet the CIA agent got
that who gave them the specialized
charge he come from
he had Chinese with him and he said I
will meet you out there to give you this
device because I can't trust anybody
to have this device in case you're
caught between now and then I said
there's no way we're gonna find you out
there this is impossible he says don't
you worry about it
you get to this coordinate and I will I
will find you that's impressive and he
did we got to that coordinate and we
waited and we waited next thing I know
he come right out of the jungle and
there he was we were gonna kill him we
thought was NBA yeah of course
I need Zola naka 'less was his name at
Fiat pronounce it right I probably do I
can't pronounce it right a common
spelling it was he actually was a
renegade CIA agent he was a desk jockey
that wanted to prove that he could be an
infield agent as the story finally went
that we didn't learn about this until
what about 12 years ago yeah and did you
meet him yeah later no no no no no one
knows where he went or what happened to
it we met another CIA guy we needed that
was actually a counterpart to a Russian
KGB agent that when they D D finally
admitted and Declassified the Vietnam
War
mitad they had 3000 Russians helping the
the NVA and they had a reunion and they
did an actual video of the reunion
admitting that they had worked with the
NVA in the Chinese in helping the the
NVA go up and down the Ho Chi Minh Trail
well this Zola nachus had figured this
out and got a hold of this device and
how we learned about it was this CIA
agent had gone there and helped
declassify all the records of Special
Ops stuff that was they were they had
located and he hold here they found my
name in the KGB at files in Moscow twice
my code name and my real name and the
missions that I ran they did that twice
and they found Lin because we bumped
into a what we I thought was a Mexican
spanish-speaking person speaking broken
English and I'm from California right I
go back to my old days and I told Lynn I
said this this guy's Mexican gotta be
what the hell's he doing out here and
he's talking to us on the radio he's got
our frequency and Glynn says give me
that football so he goes back and forth
with he mean and he says you got to move
out of the area he says I'm not going to
move out of the area I'm here to stay
here's my coordinates he gave him a five
digit coordinate no what are you gonna
do he says well nothing but you need to
move out of he was trying to save our
butts because he he was from Angola he
was a Cuban stationed in Angola and had
been shipped of lost layoffs and then
turned around and he hated the
Vietnamese so much he was trying to help
us but we could see him on the other
side of the river that where we were at
on this particular mission and so that
mission was in the KGB files that we had
spoke to him and he had our
they knew it was Artie Idaho and that we
knew it was letting me and so that as
much because we had spies in Saigon
giving all this information out knew he
had a spy that that they finally caught
an American it was giving all this
information now but for two missions I'm
in the KGB files so on this oil drum
mission we get down there after we've
been given the device at night and I go
in and I grab a hold of a drum of course
they have those little lips on there and
I can pull that drum and they're full of
about three-quarters because they got to
be buoyant and I bring that fuel drum
right to the side and I'm holding it
there and Gunther unscrews it that bug
off and puts the new one in it screws it
up tight now I've got to get that drum
back out into the flow while the flow is
NVA walking it down with bamboo poles
pushing them around so I get it out
there but I can't get back because here
they come so I had to go under and hold
my breath but I can't hold my breath
that long this water is ice-cold right
but fortunately I was a great swimmer in
my youth and I could I could handle this
but I could get my nose just above the
surface blow out and take a breath and
go back under but because it's dark and
they went on by me finally but I thought
for sure they'd stick me with the
weather one of the poles but they pushed
that drum on down and the few drums that
were around me and I came back to the
edge and crawled out but I was so cold I
can hardly move I'm soaking wet of
course and Gunther says come on we got
to go and I finally put my gear back on
my rucksack in the radio and my web gear
and everything else back on and up the
hill we go but I'm still just barely
making it just barely make
I'm so stiff and we crawled out of there
took two days to get out but that device
was set for two days but they hadn't
gone off yet but we finally got
extraction orders in and they came in
goddess and strung us out and when we
were on strings it went off McCovey
right it was there and it was like an
atom bomb it was a miniature mushroom
and the shockwave
even though we were miles away came
through us on strings and the choppers
and just like this and we're going like
this back and forth and and the chopper
and in the cubby plane is is shaking
like this and I mean it was like an
atomic bomb just went through us what
you picture when you see and then then
everything became calm and mission
completed that's a good one that's a
real cool that's a good I knew never
knew well they didn't know until the
Russians knew yeah other than that they
never knew who what and we weren't
allowed to talk or tell anybody in camp
when we got back they just what were you
doing just another day in song and that
was what we said because we weren't even
allowed to tell anybody what we did
because of the CIA mission that we ran
but we everybody had certain things that
they did like that but it was the first
time had never been accomplished what
did you notice about the one zeroes that
you had from a leadership perspective
that you remember us like yeah this is
this is the quality some of the
qualities that they had from a
leadership perspective that you would
follow him I was most fortunate I think
I had great one zeroes some of them not
as great as others but
when you my first one he was my idol
because my first two missions and
Thanksgiving of 68 and Christmas of 68
and I you can't ever forget those you
know and so in fact the mission of 68 is
where I got the skip from the bloat up
radio that let him know he was walking
into an ad letting tilt know that he was
walking into an ambush and I'm laying on
a trail with the radio on and heard this
my interpreter comes up and interprets
what's going on I managed to get ahold
of spider parks he just had me going by
for a radio check and I told him what's
going on he radios to the tilt to turn
around and go back that he had Intel and
tilts going what yeah is the first time
I ever had like a direct Intel report do
not go through the Northeast this is the
Christmas Day mission we were on top of
that Knoll and Lynn and I had talked
about that was the one quiet area
probably there's a problem but we were
talking that spider goes do not go
through the Northeast we have an Intel
report do not go there only Intel report
that never happened before or after one
alive mission we're on the ground and we
didn't know what to help us but they
were right we didn't you noticed or we
could extract us and we're back in base
a few days later him above a connect and
it's gone like well were you on the
ground at Christmas and then we found
out that he had that Intel report that
was confirmed the one place we could
have gone we shouldn't have our
instincts were right but we had the
confirmation from the Intel report and I
was just amazing you know to this day
they got out of it and due to other
factors they got out of it but just that
it saved the team was walking into an
l-shape ambushed it had been slaughtered
and they were they were pushing them
that way with trackers gunfire and
everything else
and so they just just like you say the
gods were always with us sometimes but
at that very next day I'm still on the
trail where we were signed that was the
trail for my very first mission we we
got into North Vietnam into it called
nickel steel and I've been laying there
for four days through this process and
Gunther was I
I mean Childress was my one zero and we
were taking turns and it had been two
foliated with Agent Orange and so we had
a pretty good view and all of a sudden I
saw six point men coming up MDA I'm up
there at the trail behind a log they're
down below I give him the signal I give
him the signal I got six and I can see
him and Childress right away knows
what's going on
so he's preparing the team to fight and
exfil out of the situation but he can't
with me up above but here comes one of
the NVA he comes right up to the log and
steps over and steps right on me I put
my car 15 into his belly and I pulled
the trigger all twenty wounds made a big
gapping hole all the way through him
threw him over the log and I'm on the
run and I've got the radio and down the
hill we go
and here comes 200 NBA and their point
chasing us and we're we're bringing I'm
trying to get TAC air on the line I
finally do we're putting TAC air between
them and us and I'm throwing smoke over
my shoulder yeah yes is anything
anything in this smoke feeling and
finally they bring the some slicks in
and pull us out and and and get us out
of there on strings the odd strings
again and on the run and so the side
note to the whole mission is I don't
know how many we killed but it was not a
good day for them
but that Agent Orange was the only time
I was ever near it and right now I've
got stage 4 cancer from Agent Orange was
a limited amount of time left
so that's why I'm glad I'm here to tell
a few stories I'm glad you're here to
airborne the so how many tours did you
do was that what one tour I signed up
for why I volunteered to go in Special
Forces when I was Regular Army I
volunteered Regular Army went through
got Special Forces volunteered for
Vietnam volunteered for CCN and SOG and
and did one tour and went back home and
became a weapons instructor for Special
Forces training group and and got out
it's how many years was the total three
three years three years that was it and
then what you do when you when you got
out I kind of went back to rodeo and
training horses and things like that and
then I sort of got calm got your PA's
license yeah I got my pilot's license
fixed wing and rotary where you got home
how long did it take to kind of adapt to
the civilian life it took about a year
that because I slept with my car 15 and
then when I was in training group I
always had all the weapons around me I
felt safe but it you know fourth of July
it was always a hard one with stuff
going on you don't know and it took me a
while to do to calm down and not because
I had a lot of kills and you just have
to work through all that all the time
and I was pretty good because not after
that period of time you know we never
talked to each other we weren't allowed
to talk about it for 20 years as what I
was told so I never ever talked to
anybody I never met anybody until 2000
did you guys I mean when you when you
guys didn't keep in touch
you guys didn't write each other or each
other's health and I wrote each other
but he his family moved
I only had his mother and father's
address and I lost contact for 25 years
I moved he moved my parents moved and so
the commo drop but we were down if there
was no books no yeah nobody could say
anything what about other team members
other guys was there anyone that you
kept in touch with over the next 20
years
no so when you were done you were done I
was done your didn't your day was over
yeah because I couldn't find anybody I
didn't know anybody to talk to so I was
just done and I just let in my life just
I never thought about it anymore you
know I I knew I did stuff but I couldn't
talk about it and I had gotten married
and I told my wife about it but we just
thought that we didn't know where
anybody went I didn't know where anybody
went to and then all of a sudden the
internet came about I typed in SF one
time and a couple of emails came up old
ones I typed in McCluskey mmm God he was
working as a medevac pilot and he called
me and he was on shift and he saw it and
he called me he gave me tilts phone
number and I called tilt the next day
was Easter Sunday year was half 2000
yeah we're going to get ready to go to
church I haven't I hadn't seen him since
1968 our 69 and where were you living at
the time I lived up Bayou cemani
National Park in the town called
Mariposa beautiful and you were just
down and in Oceanside yeah
working at the paper to fish rapper so
I said well shoot you know I could so I
got the phone number and I called him on
Easter Sunday he was going out the door
to go to church and I said you better
sit down this is the Frenchman I did
we've been we talk every day though
because we can what did you uh what do
you do for a job so you had to kind of
continue to kind of get it out of your
system we're breaking horses or whatever
rodeo for another year after you know
phone's breaking poor poster and then
you went into the construction business
one in the construction business that my
father had gone into a private
construction for a particular person and
so that left the license open so I just
continued the license and he handed it
over to me and I built for almost 45
years I'm retired now what where did you
guys overlap what was that
did you guys overlap in Artie Idaho is
that when you guys overlapped well we
are at Fubon when he came in he came a
little bubble okay
and so McGovern got him first before I
ever talked to him and I got Bubba so we
were in camp we're training together out
at the firing range then Bob and I were
doing our targets they're doing theirs
and then when we moved he was that he
closed out F will be one is the last SF
troop there his recon team closed it
locked the gate by that time Lynn and I
were down in Danang already so we were
running missions he went down with with
a RT Virginia with gun through wall and
so they went down and ran their mission
including the famous oil drum one mm-hmm
and Lynn and I were doing our thing and
then by April my time in country was
getting close so Lynn had agreed to be
to come to one zero we had a special
mission we're supposed to go up to the
media pass we brought Doug in max
Fortenberry and an officer to go with us
on that mission we trained for the
mission crane right up to it went to the
launch site on the choppers took off
and they called us back and because two
aircraft was shot down over the target
area that day and so I was about four or
five days from de Rossi I mean they we
went back to camp they put up the Marble
Mountain so we're up there we have some
pictures from that time there and then I
walked off in Marble Mountain when I
pack up my gear and went home
so Doug stayed with Idaho jonard so from
April at the end of April all the way
through to October 69
he's with Idaho with Lynn and they ran a
load of missions and when I come back he
had just left base Butlins there so the
limb was the one zero so he and I took
turns
and then finally sergeant major goes
there's too much experience here black
you're out of here mm-hmm and I went
back to being a one zero for another
five months and it by that time he had
come home but he was in training group
mm-hmm so technically he got out of the
army after I did I got out in April and
you got out in June July September 1st
December 1st you know and so I went my I
went back to the Garden State and then
he went back to California and separate
ways and we did we had the cards and
some notes
I don't think made phone calls no and it
just led us back if we had a couple guys
I had other people I stayed in contact
with and then I just figured he got a
job with the CIA or did something
somewhere else you know and then finally
got the phone call on 2000 and the rest
is history and how often do you guys
link up now every day it's on the phone
like it's like you and Michael Charles
you know we talk almost every day and
because we can we're alive and we try
now to spread the story since we've been
Declassified like you're helping
tremendously to spread this story to let
people know that we actually there was a
secret war going on
and we were actually taking the war to
the enemy because our country had signed
a treaty saying that we would not go
into North Vietnam Laos and Cambodia or
the DMZ in which we operated in everyday
right we weren't stationed there we just
flew in by helicopters people always ask
me well how long did you fight in South
Vietnam I said I never fought a day in
South Vietnam the oh you needn't do
anything
no that's proof Yeah right it's what was
your reaction as stuff started to kind
of come to the surface and people
started talking about it it was a slow
Prince been a slow process I've got a
hold of tilt and then we saw each other
for the very first time after all those
years like he was standing on a corner
when I drove by and picked him up yeah
you know Society yeah we went to an
airshow and we started talking we had
our photo albums that we weren't
supposed to have because no pictures
were supposed to be taken look at all
the pictures that are out there
good recon men always do whatever they
want right so but it's been the slowest
as well we have a reunion now I really
and we'd have it in Vegas every October
now and it's been going on what 45 years
I pick 43 44 years worth I've been there
about 18 years now a special operation
is Association yeah and so we go there
and see each other and sit around and
drink and of course I don't drink but
you know we everybody drinks and it's a
free bar and and tell old war stories to
each other and couples lost a couple
eyes and the stories get more
exaggerated and but we we have a we have
the output problem is we're dying faster
than then you can were we were losing
about 10 or 12 tops six seven in the
very beginning now we're losing over 50
a year there weren't that many of us to
start with but this is a combined all
the support troops actual recon troops
there's probably not but 45 or 50 there
don't at all because we only had what
450 recon errs cousin you talked to yeah
you know
and so we have this great reunion every
year and I just never miss it because I
don't know who's gonna die it's like
yesterday was our interpreter perhaps
two year anniversary of his death and
most everybody's going down with Agent
Orange of some kind of cancer and stuff
El DeBarge well just went down from an
accident
he was our two-star general I'm very
proud of him but at the time he was shot
go ahead Thomas sure he wasn't well I
didn't I my loss to work directly I was
under his command but my my boss at the
time just you know just absolutely loved
him and and you know tried to tell me
tried to give me quotes when he'd come
back from a meeting with bars well he's
at bar old man said this no man said
that you know he he was just at my house
not too long before that and my train
room I've got trains lyon l and he was
there and had a great but there are
roommates for a few months okay
we went R&R together i met his first son
when he was 2 months old
Wow yeah well we could you know remember
stories Alvin getting shot in the chest
yeah so two days later Eldon and Doug
went to Hawaii with their respective
wives for R&R they're there for five
days and Eldon met his son for the first
time huh his eldest son Brant
yeah Brad Brant was there so you guys
must have watched him cuz he was you
know a general in the army he was in the
limelight for sure for a military guy oh
yeah and you guys knew the whole time
you're looking at him thinking hey blue
is calm specialist fourth class yeah
that's the way we knew I could never
call him general I could never call him
a bar drawer I called him elder you know
spent for Elvan yeah and-and-and he was
the same Eldon that we met in 68 is the
same I'll know but it went to being with
us last year
mmm he was there and as we spend at
glory and know that's the way we
respected here like my son got wounded
and
Iraq he went and saw this care for that
the hospital picked up for him right
away they couldn't believe what two-star
general a little grunt yeah some of
those betcha he's a scout and he got
banged up with a Humvee really bad but
the Elton was here was that August 20th
2005 a couple weeks later you were in
country then no it's I didn't was in
there Oh three or four and 106 yeah
where do you know where it wasn't Iraq
yeah he was southeast of the Green Zone
okay yeah small world what's he doing
now he's up at doing heavy equipment
training okay up in the Long Beach him
and Bruno his faithful companion are
there they're doing it and just kickin
ass takin average so pretty soon have
all the licenses in place and if you
need any heavy equipment work give him a
call right on and every freshman will
build a house for you I mean what about
so you got you got you got married when
he got done is that or along the way
along the way yeah did you have any kids
I have a son and I have a daughter I've
got a grandson and two granddaughters
very proud of him I'm really proud of my
son he he has his own company in the oil
business doing really well he repairs
all the big fracking machines okay yeah
right now I am in Texas I was in
Tennessee when I'm in Texas now now that
I've found out what my medical health is
I want to try to get my grandson to know
me before I go well that's that's
awesome he's gonna be as proud you can
be as proud of you as you are of him
that's for damn sure
well they made an action figure of me so
I've left that action figure for him
that's the famous picture yes the famous
SOG the Frenchman yes I've seen it
there's a good review of it on on
YouTube I watched yeah you can go to
youtube and look up Frenchmen action
figure and it's done really well by Ryan
Peters
yeah he's did a really excellent job
even made the box and everything for it
yeah it's pretty awesome well I'll
definitely I'll definitely post the data
that picture when when this goes up when
this goes out on to the under the
interwebs as they say and you've got
your Frenchmen challenge coin I got my
Frenchmen challenge corn yeah it's right
here
the lowest-ranking challenge coming up
it makes the generals I'd be it's a PFC
challenge good it doesn't get much
better than that yeah for sure
you got anything else I think this is a
good place I mean and if you listen to
this and you think of more things you
want to say but you know I think this is
a good good spot to wrap up this one so
if you got anything to tell you got
anything else first no I
these stories you know it's funny
because even we were in base we never
knew a lot of the details and so when I
put the books together talk to other
people like the oil drums story we learn
about 40 years later that Lin black had
done the similar thing with RT Idaho
after I left right in between these guys
and it's just like lot of history that
comes out slowly like Doug has said was
anyone tracking was anyone writin down
the history as I was happening was
anyone taken the operational summaries
and compiling them somewhere they are
all destroyed that was when I left Phu
Bai
one of my Jobs was to go through and
make sure that all the drums had been no
the ashes that they'd burnt all the lot
of reports after-action reports were all
burnt and then as we pulled out of every
F OB and closed down CCN and CCS and CCC
we closed them all that everything was
destroyed there's very few after-action
reports what there are is just minuscule
reports people try to put them out on
eBay but there
there just isn't any door out that we
have been there reports of archives that
were even now begin to look into but at
a recent reunion a guy came up to me and
said hey you know if you've done your
books I got I'd like to talk to you
because my job when we close con to
meeee was to destroy all the records
yeah yeah a lot of Valor yeah we that's
that's that's why I didn't even receive
my Purple Heart for that first mission
until eleven eleven eleven really yeah
had to go back to the paperwork on it
and we had took six years and a lot of
people and we and a lot of affidavits
and a lot of this and a lot of that and
it took six years and told Diane black
my congresswoman called me one day I was
coming back from Arlington from Barry
and Gunther wall and and my Virginia
team
Donnie shoe and in bill brown William
Brown and she calls me on the phone I
don't even know who she is she says are
you Doug maternal the Frenchman I said
yes and she says I'm Diane black
congressman for Tennessee for your
district or your district and I'm in my
limousine right now and I'm holding a
Purple Heart in my hand how do you want
it presented I said I want you to pin it
on the front of our Memorial in Gallatin
Tennessee and she did on 11/11/11 Wow
yeah yeah and my guys came and watched I
had seven of my sagres come to that and
watch tilt came everybody flew there we
were there and even there we found one
Domenic's that had pulled that this
distrain out from the shrapnel uh-huh as
an eyewitness that's that was a key
thing we got the CEO to do a letter but
took a while to track it down and put it
together but we did because all the
records have been
destroyed you know so well this record
won't be destroyed right here I'm sure
that podcast one eight six one eight six
there you go but I would like to say as
a closing thing my mom and dad are both
gone my dad was a hero I he gave me
everything he had to give he was the
best father ever my mother was the best
mother I'm proud of my kids my daughter
my son what they've accomplished in
their lives
I'm proud of my grandkids and what they
do and I'm glad I have something to
leave behind yeah his mom
when she learned that my mother died I
got a phone call the next day till your
mom's dead but I'm your mom yep my mom
loved every one of them Bubba came to LA
it's said I need a bunk up for a couple
days six and a half months later and
he'd gone through the LAPD six and a
half months later he even got married he
brought his wife into the house my mom
and dad finally said enough sit up
brother for your wedding present we're
giving you an apartment but any sauger
was welcome to my mom and dad's house oh
yeah well that is awesome and as you
both should know any sagar is welcome to
come here at any time and share their
story this this door to this podcast is
open this could just become the saag
podcast as far as I'm concerned at this
point so work on it we thank you
appreciate it
tell me what I'm about yeah you've
opened up a lot of doors to people that
will hear this history absolutely and
and it there I'm sure that I'm sure
you're hearing from them till I don't
man you've been transferring some of the
messages to me what's your what's the
Twitter that you're actually looking at
right now because you have a couple I
have John SOG you have SOG Chronicles
you know which one it is
my daughter sceptres one is J striker my
initial j in the striker mine I haven't
I've fallen out the Twitter thing you
you've admitted so Instagram Instagram
Instagram is what you're doing a little
bit social yeah over yeah I'm trying to
catch up to you I might be slow but I'm
slow who've been so busy the last few
weeks between work and yes responding to
a lot of feedback from folks off of the
last podcast people want to reach out to
you should they go through through John
Frenchman yeah they can go they go great
out through is John or they could catch
me on train 153 the word train one the
numbers 5 3 at hotmail.com that's my
email this is email and then my website
is saw chronicles calm and my emails
here and I'll connect anybody with Doug
that's the old-fashioned way and
instagrams worship we're still working
on there yeah but my daughter's gotta
give me another but she went to
Tennessee so what she's out of town I'm
struggling but maybe give me a briefing
we hang up here for that but oh good
a it's such an honor to talk to you guys
Frenchman it's an honor to meet you and
you're welcome back anytime I was glad
that I could come and meet you and I
told you what happened on the airplane
I'm sitting next to somebody what are
you doing I'm gonna go doing a podcast
with a guy named chocolate Jocko oh my
god I got him on my feet whips out his
phone and it there you are and he says I
got Twitter with him I got everything
but it's my buddy yeah I mean why would
I even expect that somebody would have
it's such a small world it really is
well regardless our service were all
part of one percent or less of our
country
mmm that served the country yeah and in
combat and I'll tell you the amount of
feedback I've gotten from when you came
on tilt I mean it's been overwhelming
the number of people that just you know
thank you for your service they're gonna
pass the same thing on to you you know
you guys should know that America loves
you guys for what you did for this
country
well thank you thank you very much
you two airborne air but all the way on
would and with that SOG has left the
building
the Frenchman and Tilt have departed
awesome what an honor to have those guys
on and I got to say this right after we
got done of course we we did some more
talking and the Frenchman was was
explaining the fact that when he would
go out on a mission
every mission he would go out on he
would square away his footlocker make
sure everything was ready to be shipped
home because every time you went out he
figured he would not be coming back so
real heroes and it's awesome to be able
to sit here and talk to those guys and
what a wooden honor that is and anyways
you know actually one of the reasons
that I can sit here and talk to guys
like tilt and the French men is because
of all the support that comes in from
all of you so appreciate you know that
because as you know I don't have any
like regular whatever they're called
advertisements on here because I'm not
gonna interrupt someone like tilt or
someone like the Frenchman or someone
like btf Tony or someone like Dakota
Meyer I'm not gonna interrupt them so I
can say you know hey buy this or buy
that or whatever and I'm not gonna stop
reading
colder than hell or I'm not gonna stop
reading The Forgotten Highlander I'm not
gonna stop reading one soldier's war so
that I can you know mention a product or
something like that so to me that's not
what this podcast is about the
information and yeah the information in
this podcast is what is paramount to me
then getting it to all of you
uninterrupted is what matters because I
will tell you that I wish that I could
have listened to this podcast when I was
growing up or even when I was a kid when
I was in the teams just to just to have
this information would have been really
helpful to me so I'm not keeping it from
anyone so that's what we're doing here
so if you do want to help out which like
I said that's that's what allows us to
be able to do this that's what allows me
to be able to fly the Frenchmen out here
to sit down and and talk and tell his
story and so it's because of you all out
there supporting supporting my companies
or my books or whatever so it's
appreciated so if you want to if you do
want to help out you want to support the
podcast then you can check on orange and
main comm where we have keys for jujitsu
we have rash guards we have clothing of
all whatever sorts including jeans and
we got supplements up there people used
to ask me what supplements I take I take
the supplements that I make so join
warfare krill oil discipline discipline
go and I drink milk because it's awesome
and delicious and of course chocolate
white tea so you can get some of that
that's all at origin main dot-com we
also have chocolate or calm where you
can get rash guards t-shirts hats
hoodies all that stuff if you like the
podcast subscribe to it
and don't forget that I also have a kids
podcast called the war your kid podcast
so your kids can get in the game too
that's called the warrior kid podcast
check out warrior kids soap from young
Aiden who's making soap on his farm up
in central California that's an Irish
Oaks ranch com
there's a YouTube channel that's called
Jocko podcast and that's where we have
the videos of this so if you want to see
what the Frenchman looks like or you
want to see what tilt looks like you can
check out the YouTube channel there's
also little shortened excerpts of this
podcast I got a album called
psychological warfare that's on iTunes
Google Play other mp3 platforms it's me
talking about how to overcome little
interruptions in your game that you're
trying to win so you can check that or
we also have flipside canvas calm my
brother Dakota Meyer has that company
and he's making visual artwork for your
walls that you can hang up we also have
on it on it comm slash jock or you can
get all kinds of cool stuff on there
kettlebells jump ropes sandbags things
that you can get stronger with I've also
written a bunch of books if you want to
support you can get some of the books
way the warrior kid is a series of books
I wrote there's three of them the most
recent one is called where's where
there's a will and that book is
available right now and so where's
worrywe the warrior kid won and way the
warrior kid - which is subtitled Mark's
mission miking the Dragons that book for
younger kids that I wrote so your kids
can learn how to overcome fear the
discipline equals free freedom Field
Manual which is a manual about how to
get after it
all the little questions that you have
are
answered if you want the audio version
of that it's on iTunes Amazon music
google play other mp3 platforms and of
course there's extreme ownership which
is the first book I wrote with my
brother Leif babban and then we have a
follow-on book to that called the
dichotomy of leadership and those books
are both about leadership and how to
lead people I have a leadership
consultancy called
a salon front and what we do is solve
problems through leadership if you have
problems in your company it is because
you have problems with your leadership
so go to a salon front comm if you want
us to come and help you solve those
problems EF online this is leadership
training online it's interactive and I
always say that leadership is not an
inoculation you can't get one shot of it
and you know everything it's like going
to one jiu-jitsu class and thinking you
know how to choke people out now no you
have to train continually that's what EF
online is for its online interactive
training EF online calm
we got the muster events these are
leadership conferences musters
gatherings where we deep dive and get
granular on the pragmatics tools we have
for leading people the next one we're
doing is in September September 19th and
20th it is in Denver it is going to sell
out in fact it's getting close I think
right now yeah they've all sold out that
one will sell out as well and then
December 4th and 5th in Sydney Australia
who knows when we're going back to
Sydney but we're going this time so if
you want to come to the muster check out
extreme ownership calm and then EF
overwatch EF overwatch calm what we're
doing there is taking proven spec ops
leaders proven combat aviation leaders
and placing them into companies in the
civilian sector that need leadership so
if you need leadership in your
organization go to EF overwatch comm and
if you want to give me some feedback on
this podcast or you have a question or
you have an answer or whatever for me
I'm on Twitter Instagram and Facebook
at Chaco willing and then once again
just the deepest thanks I can give to to
John Stryker Meyer tilt and Doug
Letourneau
the Frenchman for doing everything that
they did to fight against the dark
tyranny of communism as it tried to
spread through the world they they held
the line and it's incredible the
operations that they did and it's
incredible the sacrifices that those
operators made in that time especially
and obviously the ones that did not come
home and to the rest of you that have
served or you are serving thank you for
keeping us safe from today's threats
which are vast and equally evil it is
you that keeps us secure and keeps our
way of life secure into our police and
law enforcement to the firefighters out
there to the paramedics
EMTs dispatchers correctional officers
Border Patrol Secret Service and and all
other first responders you are on call
every day you are waiting when we need
help you are there so thank you for
keeping us safe and to everyone else out
there remember what the Frenchmen
remember what the Frenchman said after
his colonel got done explaining the
treacherous situation that they were set
to go into when that Colonel asked if
anyone had any questions the Frenchman
replied where do you need help
where do you need help it's a simple
question but it's a powerful one there's
people around you that need help ask
them what it is they need ask them where
it is that they need help and then get
up and lock and load your sawed-off m79
or whatever tool it is that you need to
unleash to give them the help that they
need and until next time this is Jocko I
hope